الى تطوراتي في اوكرانيا حيث اعلن الجيش
استعاده اكثر من خمسه كيلومترات مربعه من
الاراضي على المحور الجنوبي للهجوم المضاد
كما قال انه سيطر على بلده كليشييفكا جنوب
ضخمه شرقي البلاد جاء هذا الاعلان بعد
يومين فقط من تاكيد الجيش الاوكراني
السيطره على بلده اندري ميثا القريبه منها
واحراز تقدم باتجاه بلده كوردوميسكا واضاف
الجيش الاوكراني انه يواصل تصديه لمحاولات
الجيش الروسي الهجوم على محوري افدي افكا
ومارينكا في منطقه
ونشر اللواء الثالث التابع للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه شريطه فيديو قال انه لعمليه
تنشيط بلده اندري ميسكا التي اعلن عن
استعاده السيطره عليها من قبضه القوات
الروسيه قبل ايام وكان الجيش الاوكراني قد
استعاد السيطره على اندر ميثكا بعد ايام
من استعادتها السيطره على بلده كليشيفكا
جنوب مدينه باخموت في اقليم دومباس شرقيه
البلاد كما اعلن الجيش الاوكراني عن تقدمه
صوب بلده كوردو ميفكا على نفس المحور
وقال الجيش الاوكراني ان دفعته الجويه
اعترضت الليله الماضيه كل الصواريخ
والمسيرات الهجوميه التي اطلقتها روسيا
باتجاه اوكرانيا وقال انه دمر 17 صاروخا
مجنحا موجها اطلقت من قاذفات استراتيجيه
في منطقه فولوغراد واعترض ثماني عشره
طائره مسيره مفخخه من نوع شاهد فوق مناطق
دينيبرو وبولتاافا
وقال ان روسيا اطلقت 24 طائره مسيره على
منطقتي
بجنوب اوكرانيا خلال الليل